i didn't just sit down and write i had
to figure out okay how do i dig deeper
why do i want what do i want to say and
no one can tell me that you got to
figure out yourself right
i think you've said that good writing
demands honesty and a large degree of
emotional involvement
yeah
i certainly believe it
i think it's the most difficult part of
the equation
um
there's certain concepts like
honesty or freedom you know that i know
what it is but i can't define like what
is honesty
um
i feel like you know when you're being
honest
and that's why
intuition is such an important part of
it
you only you can know that you can and
you you got to be honest first of all
with yourself
and that's why i questioned the notion
of idea so much which is i had a great
idea
is it honest
[Music]
does it resonate does it tingle you know
[Music]
no
then let it go
i mean of course you know
if you can have a lot of ideas that's
great we all do but it's just
is this the story i want to tell is this
what i want to talk about right now
and i'm talking strictly from if you
have a choice right i mean
again if you're if you're hired
you got to find your honesty within that
material because
it's first and foremost a job
right you're an artist but you're
getting paid to do something
so
if you have a writer and gotta write a
procedural
well find your honesty
[Music]
and make it work without within that
frame but if you're writing your own
story
um we're we're all constantly changing
uh right and we're not the same person
we were two or five years ago
so what you're going to be interested in
now or what resonates is not going to be
the same thing
and that's the problem sometimes with
rewrites which is you wrote the script
at a certain point in your life
and then maybe you have to rewrite to
rewrite it two years later and you're in
a different point in your life so
it's really hard because you have to
reconnect with that emotional you know
state
and maybe you know maybe you wrote that
script when you were getting a divorce
and you were heartbroken and it was so
raw and so real and now two years later
you've gotten over your divorce and
you're perfectly content by yourself
you're like oh my god i gotta go through
that again
you know
and and it is part of the challenge i
mean you get through it through craft i
guess
or you go to the memory bank of emotions
but um
[Music]
because it's not like i mean it's not
like you have to be in a constant state
of emotional turmoil right
actually that's the worst thing to write
but you you must have gone through the
experience to know that it's real and
that you know what it feels like um
so if you ask me to just describe what
honesty is i don't really know but i
know when i'm being honest
and it it takes courage and it takes you
know and it's exhausting you gotta tell
yourself
this is not truthful when i'm writing
it's good writing yeah sure i'm a good
writer but this is not the story i gotta
tell
um or i can do better than this
or i gotta dig deeper
right now this morning i was working i'm
rewriting something
um
and i i wrote a pretty
decent first draft i'd say
and i sent it to the right people the
people i trust and they gave me great
feedback
great
um very very profound
and they said you gotta be careful
because you did a good job but
this is a bit superficial
you gotta dig deeper
if you don't want this to be
um
a bit lame
you gotta dig deeper and this is not
what the story is about like your story
is not what you what you're saying it's
about it's not really about that
so my honesty there is to say they're
absolutely right
and i had a vague feeling about it and
they're telling me that and i gotta
listen to it
um so the challenging thing is
so this morning you know i didn't just
sit down and write i had to figure out
okay how do i dig deeper
why do i want what do i want to say and
no one can tell me that you got to
figure out yourself right you can ask
friends but they're not going to have
the answer because only you know your
material so you know i've been trying
meditating
and i'm new at it so i don't really know
how to do it but just like you know
closing your eyes taking deep breaths
and trying to go deeper within and
see if something comes out of that
like what do i actually want to say
through this
uh and it's that process of you know
being patient with yourself but also
don't get don't get distracted you know
be patient but don't do like 10 minutes
and move on to something else because
it's very easy oh i have to answer some
emails you know
no no no no don't get distracted take
the time
figure it out
um
[Music]
so i don't yeah it's it's i don't know
what the answer is i know that
you you get a first and foremost be
honest with yourself
and you went to
people for feedback who didn't
totally just gush over it they but then
they didn't rip you apart so they gave
you
this is great but i need you to go
deeper there's more to this this is just
skimming the surface
their feedback uh confirmed that they
were the right people to give it to and
they
identified the problems that i suspected
myself without me having to say it
[Music]
and they gave me the right amount of
validation and said you know it's not
that
far away you're not you know it's closer
than you think
but
this is
one of the best feedback i got actually
was you're missing a part of the
equation
um so this this this guy and i wanted i
wanted to be the producer he said um
well i don't know how to explain it
without well i'm not going to reveal the
whole story it doesn't matter what i'm
saying is
there's an object that produces an
emotion in someone right and she's
trying to understand
why
she's reacting the way she is to the
object
and this guy said it's not about the
object you're making it about the object
and the answer is that
there's something happening in her life
before the object comes into it and
she's not aware of it she thinks her
marriage is perfect she thinks her
professional life is perfect
and what the object does is reveal that
it's actually not as great as you
thought
so
the object itself doesn't mean that much
yeah sure you can explore what it is but
it put you know it it causes if if her
life is like a pawn it's the stone that
causes the ripple effect
so i'm like
mind blown
yes
yes good point
it's missing emotional impact because i
haven't done that part of the work
so it's an object that reveals an
unraveling i was making it about the
object itself
and that's too cerebral you know
like no you can then figure out why the
object has that effect on her
but it's not about that it's about
herself and how little she actually
knows herself
and how
that the whole thing unravels and she
realizes wait a second do i actually
love my husband i thought i did
does he actually know me do i know
myself
my job i thought it was so stable and
you know
and this woman who is this woman my
mentor you know
which is an interesting script to write
but i mean it's it's it's hard you know
it's not as easy as
yeah they want to win the tournament can
they make it can they get to the finals
you know that's another story
that's a progression here the
progression is not as clear i mean you
gotta figure out okay
it starts off with the object it ends
with her discovering herself
i gotta fill out the rest you know
what's the journey
and there is no clear-cut answer i mean
only each person has their own
way to answer that
um
see but that's
talking about challenges that's a
challenge this script is driving me
crazy i mean
why did i put myself in this position
well i guess because i um
i don't know
it's what i have to write right now
and that's what you were talking about
maybe earlier is just getting lost in
the story and all great writers will go
through that maybe just because it's not
going to be clear-cut
um well this is the thing um sometimes
you come up with an idea and
[Music]
i don't know how commercial what i'm
writing this thing is but this is one of
those scripts i'm writing for myself um
because it's almost the end of the year
and i can i mean i've you know while i'm
waiting for a contract to come through
i'm like i'm going to write this now
um
if you want to be more commercial of
course you can't be that um you know you
got to be more
grounded i guess
um so you can find references and i you
know i always tell my students um
steel still not in terms of content
still in terms of structure right
find comps find
movies that are similar to yours
and break down the structure
not that not what we're actually seeing
i'm not saying steal characters steal
dialogue no that's awful what i'm saying
is
if is your movie similar to wes
anderson's style then
go check out the royal tennis balance
and see okay scene one character a
says this thing to character b scene two
so the structure how how does it evolve
and then you can fill out that structure
with your own ideas
and this is
this is the history of art right because
you're not really stealing because it
will never resemble that work because
by stealing it it's becoming yours
and i mean
the whole history of filmmaking and
and storytelling works that way right
shakespeare was stealing from the greeks
it's fine because you're not stealing
the essence you're stealing the
structure um
so i do that all the time i look for
comps
i study the structure
especially if they're great i'll see
what they do even the subplots i'm like
look they have this subplot interesting
was it necessary i don't know but it's
great it adds flavor to it
um
yeah
what do i need what why don't what don't
i need
what can i get rid of
what was the structure of night crawler
um nightcrawler for example it's a very
uh it doesn't innovate in terms of
structure it's um it's a very clear
progression
um
it's about a guy living in the margins
of society
um
he's not even a part of society and he's
there's something off about him so it's
how he takes advantage
of a crooked system to escalate in it
until you know
uh the flaws in it it's interesting
because he has no arc
so in terms of structure it's actually
it's if you if you check this it's very
easy to recognize the inciting incident
of you know the first act break the
midpoint the low point it's it's it's
almost it's external almost it's obvious
because the movie's not about that the
movie's obviously about escalation
what's interesting is that this guy the
hero is an anti-hero and um
he doesn't have an arc
so
usually it's desirable for characters to
have an arc
to learn something so to say to change
to evolve
this guy since he is
a sociopath
and it's really hard to identify with
him
but he's also a victim of the system he
doesn't change
and it's how he ends up winning
so it's a very pessimistic story it's a
moment about how this awful guy finds
his niche and exploits it and his people
around him and
yeah makes a lot of money and doesn't
pay the price for it
but the structure it's very easy to copy
or learn or borrow from because it's
just the beats keep escalating
what about the rene russo character does
she have an arc
uh she has a little bit more of an arc i
think um
it's a descending arc you know in the
sense that she doesn't get any better
she actually succumbs to this guy's
ambition like never-ending ambition
uh she's a bit more human in that sense
um
it's it's a weird movie because it's of
it kind of feels like a movie with a
message and movies with a very strong
message
you know it's not very dramatic to have
a very strong message
you know like um
movies shouldn't be a vehicle for uh ex
exposing an idea
no
no i mean
again i don't mean to say how things
should be it's just that you don't want
to be didactic you know you don't i i
don't like movies that tell me what how
to feel or think
um i like movies to contradict me or you
know make me question my own beliefs
and nightcrawler in a in a weird way
gets away with that
i don't feel like they're lecturing me
but it's about like look how awful the
society is
right like
look how obsessed and addicted we are to
the news cycle that
even this guy producing news is well
received
um
i don't know look i'm
i might be wrong about this because i'm
thinking about network speaking of that
back and and and
back in the day
1976 i think and network has a very
strong message and i love it so
i guess it's all a matter of how you do
it